I'm definitely excited to be talking
here because so this is actually my
first PI data and I also enter my first
Pike on this year so you know the drug
addiction has been started so that would
be a good thing so yeah and I also I
pack some stuff in here and I want to be
conscious of time so I apologize if I
talk quickly you could feel free to
interrupt with questions but just to
give you an idea of the pace of the talk
and this little set here the first
element of the Ray is who I am the
second one is what I do the third one is
where I do it and the fourth one is the
best place to get in contact with me so
I do work at context relevant now it's a
machine learning and distributed compute
company in Seattle but almost all of
what I'm going to talk about today was
done while I was employee here at
Microsoft actually so what do you need
to know about me what's actually sort of
more important what you need to know
about me is what I am NOT right so I'm a
data scientist I'm not a production
programmer and anyone who's done a code
review with me will contest that that is
definitely true but I'm getting better
don't you worry but that's why I a man I
work a lot though with developers right
so if this is me who is them them as
developers these are real programmers
right people that know what Malik is and
people that have lunchtime discussions
about Haskell and Python generators and
love the yield from abilities in Python
3 all of these things and the problem
though is that when you want to build an
experimentation platform you need both
of these people I'm definitely of the
opinion that when data scientist
developers work together they can create
something that's better than either of
them can create on their own and
actually that's what I did for about a
year at Microsoft is I work on building
a large scale experimentation platform
right so when I say large scale i do
really mean large scale like tens of
millions of users with hundred billions
of requests every day and there are
certain things that go on when you start
to scale at that size but perhaps the
most important thing that happened is we
couldn't really communicate when we
first started building the
experimentation platform so they decided
to say this is how you do randomized
control trials or experimentation or a/b
testing this is what you want to call it
a lot of the developers were like ok I
have no idea what that is and all of
this code you wrote is trash because I
can't run it for a hundred thousand
users let alone ten million users so
there's a lot of like tension about like
how do we resolve these differences
right and it actually sort of
organically came about that
writing unit tests and communicating
with each other in unit testing was a
great way to do that because everybody
understands whether or not a test passes
right if the code runs no assertion
errors your test passes everything is
good so a data scientist can then write
unit tests that the developers can work
with and go back and forth about and
once all of those tests pass you have
sort of this robust you know magically
of course you have this robust
experimentation system that gets you
exactly what you need right so it's
reducing the task of building this
abstract thing called an experimentation
system to writing a set of unit tests
the passes of which result in the
product you want right it's not that
crazy right that is test-driven
development so I'm not like a hardcore
TDD person though so you know no
pitchforks and torches or anything like
that but but normally when I talk about
these kind of things I want to hopefully
I will prove this to you that unit
testing is useful for this for this in
the next 30 minutes or so but normally
when I talk about experimentation I just
assume this is something that everyone
does all the time and everyone does
they'd be testing and everybody has
products that our consumer facing so I
always skip over this and that is the
biggest mistake I make an almost all of
these talks right so for just one second
I want to expose a lot of my biases
about what I think experimentation is
and why we need it and and and specific
what I mean when I say experimentation
right so there's question of like who
needs experimentation and obviously I'm
of the opinion that we do and when I say
we though I mean like we in humans right
so it's not actually too overly dramatic
to say that most of the scientific
scientific truths we know from
experimental lab science have come about
because of hypothesis testing right so
we know aspirin helps with heart attacks
because someone did a randomized control
trial of that so if you go to the
emergency room and you complain of heart
pain before they even take you back
there they give you two aspirin because
they know that works and they know it
because of control trials so how do we
know the Higgs boson likely exists right
you probably read some popular articles
about how the Large Hadron Collider got
a six sigma result what does that mean
null hypothesis was something aka Higgs
boson doesn't exist the result we got
was six standard deviations away from
the mean of that null hypothesis that is
how we know it exists so this is how we
collectively decide what is true and the
canonical example we always have of why
people should have done this but did in
the past is bloodletting so back in the
day if you got sick they thought it was
something inside of your blood so
people's blood would be let
is one of the few known photos false
color obviously of someone having their
blood let out and you see a lot of times
people say oh we need experimentation
because people did dumb things like this
right well that's not the only reason
you need it all right so only to sort of
help us not make mistakes mistakes are
fine anyone who's written code and never
made a mistake is probably lying to you
so I actually think there's a better
reason to say why we need
experimentation and it came when I was
reading this book called stiff by me by
roach and she has like first off you
should read this book it's amazing it's
sort of like a bill bryson like popular
science exposition of cadavers and like
what we use them for and all of these
things and she has a chapter in there
that's very insightful and it's about
like medicinal uses of various cadavers
so that's all I'll say on that you can
read the book for the rest of it but you
know it's it's pretty common most people
understand it that you know in varying
cultures around the world for true and
not so true reasons people believe in
the middle uses of lots of things right
so crushed rhinoceros horn will help you
do this or it was believed back in
feudal times that like the saliva of the
King would keel all of your wounds and
stuff like that right so this falls into
the category of stuff you're like well
I'm not sure if that's true or not and
you can come up with a number of
ridiculous examples of why people
shouldn't have done this well they
should have been smarter but the
interesting about that is had people not
been mucking around with this we
wouldn't we likely would have been much
slower to realize that adrenaline exists
and is useful epinephrine right so if
anyone here is extremely allergic to
something or anyone has asthma attacks
you will understand that adrenaline
epinephrine save your life and you learn
this because people were mucking around
with it but they weren't very scientific
about it so the whole point of
experimentation is to provide you with a
way to muck around in very creative and
free ways but do so with guardrails that
let you know when you're doing something
that is worth it that is true and when
you're doing something that is not going
to be worth it and that is false so I
think of experimentation much less of a
slap on the wrist for you know being
unintelligent about the way you go about
things and more of its a way that allows
you to be creative without necessarily
making as many mistakes as you would
have before a quick side note on that
adrenaline thing because it's just
absolutely hilarious the way they fish
they figure out that adrenaline helps
with asthma attacks is somebody notice a
doctor now doctor in quote marks this is
way back in the day a doctor noticed
that when someone is having an asthma
attack if he scared the
this out of them it stopped their asthma
attack right away so you can imagine
like these early experiments were like
he would induce asthma attacks and
people and like send them down a dark
hallway and just jump out and scare the
crap out of them and you know that's how
we started so the idea is like maybe
there's a better system to figure out
whether or not adrenaline is a useful
thing than that so what do I mean when I
say experimentation in the context of
Technology you probably have all seen a
diagram like this and lucky for you I
drew my own so it's an original piece of
art what do you do you take users you
randomly split them into two groups one
of them to show you old boring site that
you have right now and someone hired you
to do things to change it into a sweet
site that has its social it's local its
mobile it's all these kinds of things
it's way better and then you smash these
two experiences together and do some
stats and then out the other side comes
at experimental results and that result
tells you that your sweet sight was
better and don't pretend like you don't
have that bias that you think all of
your changes are always going to be
positive score cards because I know you
do and then great you get the front page
of hacker news and everyone's happy and
this like conceptually at a high level
like it is true right but I worked with
the experimentation platform here at
Bing which is amazing for just over a
year and then I set out to build my own
and real experimentation systems are
actually more like this so when you
scale up to really big ones they have
tons of stuff going on inside so when
you want to run three thousand
experiments a week on over a hundred
million people in which every user is in
a number of experiments and ninety-nine
percent of them are being run in
concurrent experiments at all at the
same time you end up getting something
that's just very complicated it's hard
to actually tell what's going on and so
my whole point is that when you approach
the building of this you better know
this machine works so you can add all
these bells and whistles that do things
you think are useful but unless you know
it works you're going to be in big
trouble and I say you because it's
always our fault right if you're in
charge of experimentation platform my
feature does work scorecard is wrong
your system is wrong all of these kinds
of things so you need to guard yourself
against that and this actually leads me
to my point of confusion because like I
really believe in experimentation
obviously but then i can read things
like this right so this is a headline
from a blog post that said how
Optimizely which is a third party very
popular website a be testing company
almost got me fired right so this person
has a little bit of a grudge against the
EOB testing what happened here is that
this person began to run a bunch of a a
test which is where you run a normal
experiment but you show the same thing
in both arms and they were getting back
significant result after significant
result after significant result this
caused them to lose a lot of faith in
their experimentation platform so much
so that they publicly called out another
company to do this there's another one
how a testing how I increase my
conversions the 30 cent by doing
absolutely nothing so again you know
same sort of scenario somebody got a
little suspicious of their platforms so
they started running a test and surprise
surprise got a ton of significant
scorecards the thing that absolutely
kills me about this is the conclusion of
this it wasn't you know I should
understand hypothesis testing better the
conclusion of this article was a be
testing is worth us so just do what you
want anyway and I I say that because
like people's belief in scientific truth
and the scientific method is extremely
shaky right so we have like congressman
in the United States who come to the
Senate floor and throw snowballs and
prove that that means global warming is
not there so like you have to be really
careful when you build an
experimentation platform because it's
very easy for people to lose faith in it
so again it is important to make sure it
works the first time around so my sense
of confusion is in that like a bee
testing is all simultaneously this thing
that Forbes writes about that lifted
Facebook and Microsoft and Google to the
pinnacle of success and optimization and
at the same time it's just crap and
nobody should do it in this worthless so
like how do you deal with these
juxtapositions so I'm going to claim
that when you build it you just need to
think about the process and think about
your scenario versus reality and I'll
expose some of these you know test
things we'll dive into the code so
peeking in my bias again like this short
little bias here will show you like
really how I think about everything that
comes to experimentation so I have an
analogy where I say reality is to the
logs that we view in the same sense that
experimental truth is to the scorecard
so there's a reality out there someone
either likes or doesn't like your site
they like the way it's interacting they
enjoy the features or they don't and
then there's the logs you collect on
their behavior and those are one
particular view of that reality you
don't really know it is this is sort of
exposing my like my physicist upbringing
that there's a reality and there is some
mathematical construct we have we do it
well that's very much the same in that
when I run an experiment there is a
truth that thing worked or it didn't
work and the point is the
experimentation system should try it's
best to tell you through a scorecard
whether or not you are right or wrong in
this outcome but the point is that they
both have their limitations and design
an experimental system that is aware of
its limitations and avoids making the
biggest mistakes is one that will serve
you very well if you do one that just
gives you answers or tells you the kinds
of things
you want to know you're going to be in a
little bit of trouble and my my view on
that is you can write unit tests that
avoid those problems so where do we
start so I'm going to assume you all
have a product and a platform of some
kind if you don't I don't know meetup
make a start up and get one and I'm just
going to add two little complicated
boxes to this thing right so to
complication box amad to this is usually
you don't just randomly split users with
the script you have some kind of
especially in large scale system some
kind of treatment assignment service
script service whatever you want to call
it but you're going to give a collection
of users to this service or users one at
a time and it is going to return to you
what bucket there in what treatment
they're going to see right and this can
be a complicated thing then on the other
side after you show them the treatment
and the control before i do any stats
i'm actually going to combine these logs
and i'm going to get what i call like
this experimental log this raw log for
experiments and in that aggregation is
another point where you can fail
catastrophic lee so I'm actually just
going to concentrate on these two boxes
in this use case here right so we're
going to dig into each one of those
boxes and the left side like I said
that's sometimes what you refer to as
bucketing and bucketing can be difficult
because random numbers are hard and will
explain that in a little bit and then
the other side this scorecard in this
aggregation it can also be difficult
because counting and aggregating can
also be not obvious and difficult and
people make mistakes there so there's
lots of talks out there about how people
mess up hypothesis testing cuz they
don't understand statistics but nobody
talks about how you can mess up
hypothesis testing because somebody
wrote a sequel query incorrectly right
the same kind of thing can happen
there's this no reason to think that
can't happen either the whole point is
that unit testing can help with the
ladder and sometimes with the former but
I also say it's critical to know that
your platform works because users are
crazy they do weird things you don't
know some of them use a phone that
you've never seen before and it creates
an instrumentation bug that you don't
know and then you log it and you don't
know till afterwards and somebody has to
go in by hand and look at it and so the
whole point is any automated tests i can
write the helps me avoid that is good so
what would a test look like so this is a
mock-up of a test that i wrote and hand
it off to a dev team when i first got
there because they said i have no idea
what you mean by writing unit tests for
random data what does that mean so i
just hand it off this mock up to them
and I said look so here might be one of
these in your test class they said it
just test the bucket split that left
hand thing I talked about before so what
is it going to do well it's going to go
through every metric in your bucket of
important
that you care about you know email open
rate click through whatever your metrics
happen to be and it's just going to ask
are the differences between the two
groups you gave me less than some
tolerance right this is what it means to
test the difference between two random
groups right I have two groups they have
some summary of those two groups and I
just want to know that they're close
enough that i would consider them the
same now economically you might think oh
I want to make this make sure that like
it is exactly equal to zero if you do
that your test will never pass
congratulations but again this is this
is the this last line is a statement of
hypothesis testing are two things close
enough for me to consider them the same
and they thought this was great and then
they realize when they went to implement
this that like where do I get group a
and B we haven't run an experiment we
can't run an experiment until we have an
experimentation platform how do I go
find these things I don't just want to
pull logs to random places for various
reasons so they gave that back to me I
said that's a good question I didn't
think about that and my complicated
three lines of programs I didn't think
of these two things so I went away for a
little bit and I thought I came back and
I said why don't I just make some fake
humans for you so the whole point was
there's a lot of pushback because the
idea is that well this platform needs to
serve 10 million people and it doesn't
matter what we do on our current
platform we're never going to get the
kind of volume I said great I'll just
make some so if you're a human this is
not very nice to say but as a data
scientist what do I think human beings
are there a collection of log lines so
when I look on the logs on my side
everyone who uses my site they are a
group by anonymous ID get everything
they did so this is actually really good
because humans are complicated log lines
are not log lines when I go to simulate
humans or at least the log lines they
would generate log lines only have a
certain range of creative expression
there's tons of things the logs don't
tell me about you they don't tell me the
expression on your face when you saw
this new feature i put on my side they
didn't tell me whether or not you got
stuck in traffic on the way to work this
morning so that when you come to work
and use my product you're using it a
different way they don't tell me any of
that there a reduced amount of
expressiveness which is great because
they want to go to simulate them I only
need to simulate that amount of
expressiveness and let's actually see
like how we would skip a human and just
make a logline how does a human make a
logline pretty simple they visit the
site you don't log people they don't
come to your site usually and but they
get to the site they have a choice they
can do something they can like
photo they can post something they can
go to a different page they can do a
search they can start typing to search
and delete back you can parameterize all
of the things they do in to sort of sets
of choices right and then the whole
point is that they have this choice in
front of them and then they make a
choice and then optionally maybe they
make that choice over and over again
depending how complicated your your
services right like think of snapchat
they open the app they either snapchat
or they don't snapchat right like
there's a few other things you can do in
there but this idea is that they're just
making a series of choices and the whole
thing you really need to take away from
this is that logs are generated by a
process you actually don't think about
this but this is an assumption you make
when you do an all hypothesis testing is
that you assume things are generated by
a process and so let's abstract that
process a little bit to think about how
the computer things about i think the
keynote yesterday was really great
because he pointed out that one thing
you need to teach children when you
teach them how to program is that
computers only know what's right in
front of them and they're really dumb so
you have to tell them exactly what's
happening so how does a computer do this
process easy you present a choice what
is the choice to a computer it's a
probability distribution no problem
probability represents your entire
universe I can do this set of things
with this probability but it defines my
entire universe then the human makes a
choice that's a draw from that
distribution this is great because these
are all things computers can do we know
this number three given that choice
maybe I'm going to make a new choice and
maybe this time the probability
distributions different but it's still
just another draw that's great and after
I begin to see that all i'm doing is
layering these together I just have to
repeat which is awesome because this is
something computers are unbelievably
good at so if I can do one two three
four and then I tell the computer
repeats I'm good so this is actually how
you're going to build them right it's a
simple process but it really captures
the essence of the log generation so how
do I inject some flexibility to this
well you can imagine that I can use
different probability distributions to
represent different kinds of choices the
parameters of those distributions can be
different per person per group per unit
time or anything right and in a very
brute force way you can inject an
amazing amount of flexibility into this
right so let's present a choice and then
make it right so i apologize i am
definitely like a Python 2.7 person so
if you're still a 2.7 person you can
tweet awesome things at me if you are
upset with my lack of commitment of
three you can send him to Joel he would
love to hear this you should also read
his book and go to us
so what's a choice here's a function
that does a choice it's called get
Bernoulli trial it has two inputs right
so it has P that's the probability of
success here and end the number of times
I want you to make that choice so what's
a Bernoulli trial right a Bernoulli
trial is a coin flip right it's
something that only has two outputs 0 or
1 and every time you ask it for a 0 or 1
it will give you a 1 with probability P
and a 0 with probability 1 minus B right
this is a very simple thing this
represents an unbelievably large amount
of choices people make when it comes to
a weblog right so anyone knows about
Beijing hypothesis testing right in the
beta binomial model right like by Noah
models are just collections of those
things right so this is a very simple
choice so I can do this it does work
right if I have a collection of 10,000
people or one person that visits 10,000
times because they're really into your
product here's them making 10,000 of
those decisions and of course as we
might expect if I expect them half of
them to be right in half of them half of
them to have the time he takes that have
a time he doesn't take that then I
actually get that right so this is this
is nice but not all things are that
simple but math bales us out here there
are lots of probability distributions
that describe lots of processes and then
your task is to map those processes to
things you think humans do right so I
can have in the top one there I have a
draw from a beta distribution that can
help me create different probabilities
for those brewery trials that create
diversity amongst people's
decision-making I can use an exponential
one to create a population of people
we're very most people do very little
and all small number of people do a lot
that's your typical search engine
actually you can get an experimental
result I can do a ton of Bernoulli
trials all in a row that ends up giving
me a binomial distribution rights so the
distribution of successes for a number
of these individual brutally piles is a
binomial distribution and then maybe I
my users have different visit
frequencies maybe someones a constant
Facebook checker maybe someone only
checks at once a month that's great i
can use a poisson distribution to tell
me about those users to give me all of
these things so the whole point is i can
take these things and tie them together
and make a fake log so let's just make a
quick one and then we'll understand how
we're going to use this right so how do
i make a clique seem wrong easy i
imagine somebody comes to my site this
can be a probability I don't have to
always visit they can execute
newly trial this is then clicking right
so think of an email offer or something
like that so they come to cite the
either click on the offer or don't
that's going to send them to a landing
page where they either buyer they don't
that's just to Bernoulli trials back to
back so that represents the almost most
of your email campaign time-consuming so
all I do is just make those two choices
and then i'm going to log that and make
it look like a log so that i can test
things like data ingestion data handling
all of these kinds of stuff data
processing times so let's actually do
that i have this function here called
generate impression right so it's pretty
simple it takes in these three
probabilities the probability that you
will come to the site the probability
that you will click and the probability
that you will buy something right now
I'm abstracting the user behavior a lot
but remember your logs do this already
anyway so what I do I get an impression
right that's just a Bernoulli trial with
oppression here I'm cheating a bit
because I'm guaranteeing that they come
to the site usually don't log people
they don't come if they did visit just
ask me if they clicked no problem if
they did click just ask me whether or
not they converted no problem if they
didn't click i'm going to say they
didn't convert optionally people often
buy things not through your offer i can
just make that another Bernoulli trial
with a different probability where I
think they have maybe a lower
probability of buying because it's not
on sale or they didn't do something the
whole point is just with these three
Bernoulli trials you've already injected
an amazing amount of accuracy in to what
email offer general it looks like and
then I'm just going to turn this
impression right so what do I see well I
see you know what do i get i get these
three numbers right did they click did
they convert and do they have an
impression this is good but it doesn't
look like a log yet so i'm going to
generate a logline where I stick a
random time stamp and a random user ID
there right so my friend try he's going
to come to my site and same thing
happens before generate the impression
take some random time at some random
time Delta to it add it on here smash
them all together and I'll put this line
this is great it's not quite there yet
though because nobody stores user names
in plain text unless your time warner
cable and so let's hash that right so
that's not so bad i'm going to sha one
hash that that's not a big deal so i'm
just going to turn this into a dataframe
now so we have something that looks kind
of like a log i'm going to take trey i'm
going to hash his ID with the salt spurs
always let you down so if there's any
tottenham hotspur fans here i apologize
and then i'm just going to make ten logs
line 10 log lines for tray and that's
what it looks like this is really
starting to look like a log
I did three Bernoulli trials three draws
from one distribution it's about 20
lines of code but I've made something
that looks like the aggregated output of
an email offer look so this is how email
campaigns work and in fact you can
generate these and do nice things like
send these to people and say this is the
output of your experiment and just see
how much they actually believe it
because it turns out it's it's quite the
dead ringer so this is good I have this
kind of thing right but you can do more
with this right think of the formula the
formula is really simple encapsulate a
human behavior you care about into a
probability distribution there is a lot
of knowledge that goes into this right
though but if you're trying to model the
number of times distinct events happens
you have a distribution of that it's
plus on the time between those events of
exponential distribution binomial for
total wins or total clicks total
purchases little something amongst a
population of people the beta
distribution is amazing because it
allows you to eject diversity into all
of these probabilities that you have
here and then normal because it's
popular and everybody wants to use that
anyway but you don't make heavy use of
it here but you chain these
distributions together to form an
impression a user impression and then
you vary the parameters either within
the chain across users across
populations to generate diversity so
it's very easy to make controlled random
distributions of users that have
particular consistent behaviors and it
looks a lot like the behaviors you have
before right so the simplicity is
deceptive but one thing you need to
realize is that like this is actually
just beige in statistical testing
backwards okay because what do you do
there in Bay's is statistical testing
you assume the log was generated by some
kind of process and your point is to
recover the parameters of those
distributions and compare the parameters
to each other between treatment of
control and ask if they're different
well what's wrong with just doing that
backwards and backwards I inject the
parameters generate the logs and then I
want to measure them backwards again so
that is the big assumption right the
model assumption here is that these do
obey these distributions right but
you're making that assumption anyway
when you perform statistical tests so
now what does the test look like right
the test is extract the unknown
parameters this is how you write unit
tests you make fake logs that have
parameterizations probabilities of
clicks number of users things like this
and you ask your experimentation system
to faithfully recover those if it can do
that you put a known input into the
front of your black box and you've got
the correct
on the other side you know your system
is working independent of people who
have weird wacky behavior that you can't
control and that's what they are right
simulated logs are nothing more than
noisy instantiations of your supplied
parameters just recover those parameters
this is how you test random data so
Justin did a great tutorial yesterday
and there's a lot of questions coming up
about like how do you test the output of
simulations and random burials you try
and recover the parameters that
generated those random distributions and
so I say your task while the devs task
let's let's be honest who is doing the
real work here is to recover those
parameters within reason so let's
revisit that a a test and let's write
some actual unit tests in our last 15
minutes here a 10 minute or so I'm going
to return to that a a unit test run
before the test bucket split and I want
to be this very explicit about why this
is important because most people don't
pay attention to this and it's the
reason all those blog posts are going up
so when I have my users and I randomly
split them into two groups they haven't
actually become treatment and control
yet right I haven't shown them anything
different they're just two groups of
people and in fact to the left of T
equals zero where I show them treatment
and control they had better be the same
right this is the place of the better
see this is an implicit assumption of
your hypothesis that they are the same
on the right side they're allowed to be
different because one of them has seen
your awesome change and the other one
has not so we better make sure they are
the same before so let's refactor that a
test just to be a little bit more
friendly to what we have here so now I'm
going to take this bucket split test and
I'm going to give it to data frames one
of them is the control group one of them
is the to be treatment group and then
when they give a metric and I'm simply
going to ask is the p value of the
difference between those two groups
significant or not all right so before
when I said is the difference less than
some tolerance awful that's really what
you mean when you're asking this here
right so I'm just going to say when i
get the p value of comparing these two
groups either through a t-test or Z test
or your favorite awesome test song it's
going to be a t-test between these two
groups for this metric is a greater than
point 05 meaning to my knowledge to the
best of my ability can I not tell the
difference between these groups that is
what equivalent means in this in this
sense so let's do that I have some
parameters here click ctrl click convert
users in n rows I'm being a little hand
wave because I don't to go through too
much this but I have another function
called stimulate log vectorize which
will do what I talked about for inject
diversity into people by changing the
parameters and generate a bunch of logs
they look like the same when I generated
for trade but have many users with
diverse
behaviors but the important thing to
realize is that when I do this it's the
same probability for both groups right
it's the same parameters for both groups
so a and B should not be different they
might be slightly different is that any
random draw is going to be different in
any other interval but as a collection
they should not be different i generated
them with the same parameters right and
just to give an idea like they look like
this right so they just have different
user IDs the times are a little bit
different all these kinds of things but
they're just the click logs that you saw
before so now I want you to sort of ask
yourself will that unit test pass like
commit to an answer in your head this is
the fun part so if I Denner ated two
things with the exact same parameters
and I compared them to each other is
that unit test going to pass or not it
does pass this is good no assertion
error this is good this is what we
should see right I should not see a
difference between these two groups this
is really good the point is though is
this always true so if this is passing
like why am I so wary of random number
generators why do I need to confirm that
a random split is really random split
well um when I think about randomly
splitting users this is like my most
Reagan desk moment in my life because I
do trust random number generators but I
always verify them because the whole
point here is that random is random
except when it's not so let's make it
real most of the time you own you don't
only have one metric that you care about
right you have maybe many metrics that
you care about and in this case I'm just
going to write a function your ad
metrics that just adds a Bernoulli trial
column on to each one of those data
frames let's just a way for me to add
additional metrics that might be like
that p click metric right so this is
just going to take it and get a number
of early trials and just slap that on to
the end of the data frame then i'm going
to write another function called the AFA
letran and what it will do is just add
those metrics on to the group's and then
it's just going to for every metric that
you added perform this test again right
this is actually something very common
that you see right someone makes an
experimentation platform that you saw
before they add metrics as they become
important to their product and they
start out putting them in scorecards so
now the question is the name of the
function is a little bit foreshadowing
but in this range i'm going to perform
this test bucket split and metrics times
well that s ocean ever fail will i ever
get an assertion error
right I generated them by the exact same
process i generated the cliq column from
before it's nothing different about it
because the probabilities between the
two are the same right identical columns
the point is it does fail right and so
this is something that martin who did a
PI data talk I think 2014 talked about
quite a bit this is the multiple testing
problem and most people when they build
an experimentation system did not think
about this and just really nearly add
metrics as you go so what's happening
here right well why is this failing well
eventually one point I got a p-value
that was less than point 05 so my
randomly split identically generated
groups were not identical but that's
actually not surprising because the
whole point is is that every time I test
a metric I'm accepting this point 05
probability of the type 1 error and the
whole point is as I add additional
metrics i'm testing over and over and
over again the familywize error rate the
error rate that i might say taiwan area
for the whole family of 10 tests goes
above that number so i will fail I'm
guaranteed to fail at some point so this
is good because I did this before I made
a decision based on this before I got a
scorecard back that erroneously reported
the outcome because I didn't correctly
split my users into two groups so I can
actually write a function called count
dem fails which does the same thing but
instead of an assertion it just takes
the p-value and counts the number of
times it would have failed right so you
can see that if I have two metrics i
only added two metrics only testing two
metrics that in the course of creating
ten experiments or ten splits for
experiment I do actually fail one time
one of this experiments would have been
invalid because the two groups created
by random chance are not identical if I
up it to measuring five metrics I know
that seems like a naught but a lot but
email open rate email click through rate
email unsubscribe rate email subscribe
rate and then conversion there's five
metrics for winning will test it's not
that hard to come up with them and trust
me once you doing experimentation people
people love to add metrics so here's the
second one it failed four times forty
percent of my experiments that iran in
that sequence of ten had incorrect
splits in the beginning by the time it
gets twenty metrics i'm almost
guaranteed to fail well that's okay we
can correct for this or bonferroni can
correct for this so there's an
overcorrection the called the bonferroni
correction where I just require that
that family-wise error rate the whole
ten metrics error rate actually matches
what i originally want the point zero
five and I do that by just saying every
individual test I have
stricter requirement for what equal
means the p-value needs to be smaller
than that and this is a brute force way
to do that this is great I redefine
these things to take in and metrics now
and instead of comparing it to point
zero five I can direct it to the
bonferroni correction and I get this it
doesn't fail and it passes a lot great
I've added something to my code that now
does a correction on the p-values and
I've corrected for multiple testing
before I've ever made a mistake just by
Whitney of this congratulations you're
better than eighty percent of the
experimentation platforms out there most
of the big ones correct for this don't
worry about that but a lot of the
inflation you see just have no mention
of this and you already corrected it
before you even ran an experiment this
is good but here's another question will
this fail can I make this fail I just
introduced a correction that should
correct for this but is it possible for
this to fail the answer is certainly yes
if I did this a hundred times I will
fail it's still garant the familywize
error rate is that a point zero five but
if I do a hundred experiments one of
them is guaranteed to fail you expect
one of them to fail it's not guaranteed
expectation yeah the expected value is
that one will fail it's okay though this
is expected this is expected the whole
point is your platform should know this
NAA you always verify that it doesn't
fail what does that mean it means you
randomize your groups until they pass so
anytime you kick off an experiment you
don't accept the familywize error rate
that you might have instead you shuffle
them check the AAA if they pass you
proceed with the experiment if when you
shuffle them they fail the AAA doesn't
matter grab a new salt reshuffle them
you will pass then you send them into
the experiment so you just by witnessing
the failure of your test and simulated
logs can correct for this and like I
said most experimentation platforms
don't correct for this as it is this is
the multiple testing problem you've seen
so just quickly on aggregation right so
that's one way to avoid failures in a
testing those two blog posts i showed
you before they were entirely you know i
don't work at those companies but from
reading them and understand what you see
they were having a a failure sorry so
they were running tests just assuming
just resided resigning themselves to the
idea that you will have this point zero
five percent a failure rate and you're
just going to take it because it's a
small amount of tests again when you
work on a platform that runs thousands a
week and users are in multiple
experiments and you have interactions
between experiments failing one of them
is
not okay it ruins other experiments you
have to be conscious of that kind of
thing so that's one way to fix it
congratulations okay so now on to the
right-hand side of that thing
aggregating right so how do I aggregate
before hitting things with a stat stick
right so I'm just going to ask you all a
question how do I calculate just term
that simple log no 10 metrics and I
think just that click one how do I
calculate the average page click rate
per user just think in your head talk to
your neighbor pull out something right
pandas code whatever you want i want to
calculate this the average click weight
per user a lot of times what you see in
scorecard things is this take the data
frame take the cliq column and i take
the mean you asked me for the average
click-through rate don't do that that's
okay a lot of things are like that
that's one measure but don't do that why
should you not do that when you think
about real logs real dogs are made of
collections of users a lot of times it's
not a bad generalization to say that you
have a small amount of users that
generate a lot of your traffic and then
you have a large amount of users that
generate a moderate amount of traffic if
anyone's ever heard of the 8020 rule
that's the instantiation of this right
some small amount generate a lot of your
traffic that's great so I'm going to
make a data frame that has those two
things right so I have 10 users that
generate 50 thousand impressions over
some amount of time and they're super
clicky they click on everything they're
probably BOTS but that's okay that's
okay we won't tell that to our investors
then I have a thousand users and they
only generate 10,000 gross right so they
are a minority of the rose but they are
a majority of the users and they are
much less clicking so when I do that
first thing that click mean what do I
get it tells me that the average page
click right right because every
impression is a pageview average page
click rate is point six eight um that is
not accurate think about that that's a
summary statistic of that distribution
you know when you generated that most
people have a point one I have a ten
percent click the rate so when I give
you a summary statistic that says
sixty-eight percent of the time people
click that isn't in accurate summary of
what's happening it's one thing but for
your for your desiring the
experimentation is to understand what's
happening to the user that's the
misleading assessment of the user
instead you should do this thing called
double averaging right so for every user
I group by the user and I find their
page click rate and then I average
across all of those so what is this
doing this is a waiting thing the first
one is a weighted average where the
people who generate most of your traffic
are weighted more than the people who
are not generating most of your traffic
the second one is where everybody has
weight one I have removed that user
difference between everybody and there
you see the user level quick average is
point one and that's much better right
because if I dip into these users what
am I going to do well overwhelmingly I'm
going to grab people from the not so
engaged bucket and there click the rate
is gonna be ten percent and that's great
because it's exactly what I see so why
is this important let's say your
experiment has a lift of ten percent
right in CTR for your heavy users so
that's easy a distinctive set of users
increase their click-through rate by
eight percent and then what do I see on
the other side well the impression level
quicker average is shot up and we should
expect that it's overly sensitive to
these users but the user level one
hasn't really moved that much because
you haven't changed that much of users
and then this click report is just a way
to do a quick sort of experiment about
that and the idea is that yes the
impression level one measures what you
input but this is an incorrect effect
size if I release this change to
everybody I've changed one percent of my
users so to say that this experiment
will lift ten percent of your user
behavior is an inaccurate result an
accurate assessment but that's what
people will read out of the scorecard
instead I will go lift i did move
people's behavior but the effect size is
actually much smaller this thing called
average treatment effect it's actually
much smaller than then you look at it
works the other way too if ten percent
of my light users is exhibited a ten
percent lift what do I see there I'm
just adding a little ten percent lift on
ten percent of those users the
impression level average is completely
insensitive it can't see it at all
because they're on minority of those
things you didn't move the weighted
average at all but the user level one
does the tech the move so the point is
just as valuable to say them right so
you want to make sure to to write unit
tests that understand the sensitivity of
experimental platform that it doesn't
make incorrect decisions based on these
kinds of things right so you can have a
test like this correct roll up you can
give this test case I had before where
your heavy users which are a small
minority have a huge lift and you just
want to make sure that the user lift is
less than the impression lift if your
scorecard can communicate that to you
it's doing the correct thing it will
stop you from making mistakes so what
are some things you should think about
is like include here right unit testing
is common ground right it's the way non
hardcore developers can communicate with
developers I write a test the passes of
which will create a robust and useful
experimentation platform if it passes
great log stimulation is actually
surprisingly accurate so using these
logs I simulated you know a month of
behavior for various summary statistics
on bing and you know you're within six
decimal places of the exact thing right
so users aren't as complicated as you
might think the last one or the third
one is like a fear mongering thing
mistakes can exist in your platform at
tons of places and you should be very
careful to guard yourself against those
so that's like my fear mongering part of
that I don't make people think it's
impossible to make one that works but
there are mistakes they go everywhere
and the last ones this is just really
true like users are where human beings
make career decisions sometimes your
campaign doesn't work because there was
a rain storm in the northeast of the
United States and a bunch of people's
cars broke down so they couldn't receive
your email to go over Dean the offer
because they were at somewhere getting
their car towed out of a river and your
logs have zero knowledge of that there's
no way for you to know that so you need
to make sure that your experimentation
platform is telling you the correct
things and not erroneously leading you
down some paths and with that I'll just
leave this up here at the end and thank
you for your attention